this is annoying he always annoys me but
king dork neil degrasse tyson was on
rogan yeah yeah
and um and rogan put him in his place
bro that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] beautiful
because they would start talking about
ufos and you know king dork is a bah
humbug about everything he got like rain
on everybody's parade
that's his [ __ ] just he's big i know
he's so [ __ ] annoying and um
he goes he says here's my issue with uf
he's so dismissive of everything that he
doesn't agree with
like it's preposterous so you don't even
bring it up to him because here's my
thing with the ufos it's like
why would an advanced uh alien species
be interesting
about us what is so interesting about us
it's arrogant to even think that they
would even care what we have going on
here
and just no sorry go go go go go we got
people to study ants
bro like literally we go to the [ __ ]
forest and we look at bugs and we go
look at this bug and it does nothing we
were like we invented a new bug yes
jellyfish we study we study trees we
study leaves we go
lazy justification and say i don't
necessarily believe it it's just so lazy
to
and to condescend and make you feel bad
about yourself what makes you think
you're so important it's so patronizing
and so arrogant to assume that if
something is of no interest to you
yeah then it should be of no interest to
any people why do you care about stars
[ __ ]
yeah yeah it's gas
bro little specks in the sky can't do
nothing never going to eat matter of
fact the [ __ ] you're studying
ain't even around no more it's gone by
the time it reaches us stupid
you study some [ __ ] that don't even
exist like ufos you [ __ ] idiot
i'm so annoyed by this guy but joe
basically said to me he's like why would
they not be interested
we can nuke the world a thousand times
over
we have tiny disputes that end up in
massive fights wars we have [ __ ]
holocaust how do they do that to elliot
page i would travel
we have game of thrones like game of
thrones we create these movies stories
he goes there's so many things that are
so unbelievably fascinating
at any point in time we can press one
button and then there's no more of any
of us on the world anymore and we don't
and he does this long spiel and i was
like yes put that [ __ ] dork in
his place one of the most interesting
just neil degrasse tyson is boring as
[ __ ] and he's confusing himself with us
and to your point about how we study
boring [ __ ] we're interested in what
neil degrasse tyson got to say
you don't think aliens be interested in
what human beings have to say when
people listen to you
you robot you got to say some [ __ ] and
we're like oh that's interesting
so true man it just made me feel so good
for rogan to get because that's also
like if you're going to talk about some
science [ __ ]
nobody's [ __ ] with a scientist yeah
neil grassley's natural scientist
but the second they got in that ufo
thing now you're in rogue's wheelhouse
yeah
right now you're in the unprovable if
you want to go into the approval [ __ ]
that's you
but the unprovable buckle up boy well
it's been proven they exist
well ufos but we don't know if it's
aliens right right
yeah but we don't know what the [ __ ] it
was why do you think we just don't care
you really think
we just want to go outside isn't it also
equally arrogant to say this entire
universe exists just for us
that's some white people [ __ ] like you
think this whole space exists and it's
just ours
we just get to send rockets whoever the
[ __ ] we want to and that's our land
i don't i don't think he got a good
point we put an american flag on the
moon
she is mad arrogant yeah that is that we
can go to mars send a rover to mars why
we own the moon
that's kind of lit though like we got
there first that's arrogant
don't talk about arrogance when we're
when that's equally as arrogant
i think that like their their feeling is
i think musk
subscribes to this as well is uh we
don't have any proof that they've come
here
but that doesn't mean that they don't
exist and the probability is that they
do exist
because there's just so many outcomes
but we don't have any real proof that
they've been here like
and um even with the ufo footage like
this [ __ ] is always
mad grainy everyone's got an iphone now
yeah yeah
like i was using that footage back in
the 90s is like i get it like
now you got to zoom in and people should
get grainy i guess but it's like
waiting that makes that make sense when
you're doing a lot of this they're doing
a lot of this on their phone yeah i mean
i've seen world story videos like they
get some like zoom
so don't zoom then let me get this [ __ ]
just regular but then it just looked
like a little spot
okay i'm okay with the moving spot what
else
nah but i mean it makes sense for the
video to be grainy like if the
[ __ ] shits are in the atmosphere it's
not like you they're flying on the same
like distance where planes are and [ __ ]
like that so they're gonna it's gonna be
grainy
here to here you get a clear ass picture
thousand ten thousand however many feet
away you ain't getting no clear picture
you gotta zoom
yeah if your video is grainy bro
got iphone 10 yeah get it
i don't know step it up you all got to
step it up yeah you got one camera that
you got one camera
yeah get rid of the grain right like
that should be what they do
so you don't think it's ufo because it's
grainy i don't think it's ufo i think
it's our [ __ ] and i think that we're
just trying to posture
like i think we made these things and
this is us to other countries going we
don't know what it is but other
countries are like well we know it ain't
us
do these [ __ ] got some crazy
flying [ __ ] all right let me not [ __ ]
with that oh that's fine
that's what i think it is and then
china's just like hahaha the game is we
buy things now it's not who got the
fancy planes pam
the game is we buy things whoever buys
the most [ __ ]
wins so print some more money
[ __ ] like
let's start buying bro
you